westgate sportsbook was the place to be
as hundreds headed out to place their
bets on the big game
yeah brian the scene was a lot smaller
due to copied restrictions but those who
were there said the atmosphere was
nothing short of electric
sasha lofta spoke with fans and
sportsbook staff
this may be the first super bowl we're
celebrating during a pandemic
but people here at the westgate sports
book still manage to have a great time
while
socially distancing and placing some big
bets
westgate officials tell us the biggest
bet of the day came in early this
morning at 325
thousand dollars on kansas city
otherwise bets were pretty balanced
though the chiefs were originally
favored by three and a half points
many we spoke with were rooting for
kansas city but just couldn't bring
themselves to bet against brady
and hey that ended up being a pretty
smart choice
obviously the pandemic switched things
up this year but everyone
stayed safe and made the best of it it's
totally different than in years past
but i expected an atmosphere in here i
expected electricity
because americans love football they
love betting football
and they didn't disappoint today i think
people are adjusting to the new climate
with the um what's it called the shot
you know like
having the options you know to beat
covet so
people are here you know people are out
masks were of course required inside
unless you were at a table eating or
drinking
and the staff did temperature checks as
people came in now westgate officials
tell me last year they hosted about 10
000 people for the super bowl but of
course had to scale things back
significantly due to the pandemic
they hosted about 500 people this year
about 25 percent capacity
reporting from the westgate sportsbook
sasha loftis 8 news now